our tension is building between serbs
and ethnic albanians in the town of
zwechan which is a northern Kosovo
ethnic serbs have gathered outside a
city hall that is being guarded by
kosovan police they're angry about the
election of ethnic Albanian Mayors now
on Friday violence broke out when
demonstrators blocked the officials from
entering their offices Assad bank has
this update from zvetchen
local serbs here try to enter the
municipality building just behind this
police line
now what happened was the police stopped
them they fired some gas and the people
backed off but the argument they make up
the majority in these Northern areas of
Kosovo they don't believe that the
mayors that were elected are legitimate
and they're protesting
[Applause]
happiness
now NATO has asked Kosovo to de-escalate
the United Kingdom Germany and many
others are asking Kosovo to de-escalate
the situation but from the looks of it
here the amount of people that have
turned out it doesn't seem like it's
going to happen now the customer
authorities have said that they have a
right and an obligation to hold up the
Constitution that these Mayors did win
an election even though it was boycotted
by the Serb population in these areas
and the police are now have their
Shields out they have the gas masks out
they've already confronted the
protesters and NATO forces are also out
now we don't know what their mandate is
earlier on they did have a line further
up the streets but people walked
straight past them now they've had they
have a line in front of the municipality
building and the local police the
customer police are behind them but the
NATO officials have been speaking to
some of the Serb politicians here and
they've asked them to de-escalate and
ask them to tell the crowd to move off
the street and the response that we
heard was that if you ask these people
to move from this area it will
definitely not de-escalate the situation
I said Big Al Jazeera Kosovo